>> Greg: I HOPE THIS IS
GOOD -- HAPPY THURSDAY,
EVERYONE.
I KNOW I LOOK GREAT.
THOSE INJECTIONS OF PANDA TEARS
INTO MY FACE ARE REALLY PAYING
OFF.
WE MADE THEM CRY BY READING
ALOUD FROM BRIAN KILMEADE'S
BOOK.
THE ONLY SIDE EFFECT IS ME
CRAVING BAMBOO SHOOTS 24 HOURS A
DAY.
ENOUGH OF THAT --
WE ARE LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE
JULY 4TH THEMED, I'M NOT SHOWING
THE GUY BUT WE HAVE A
REPLACEMENT FOR HIM.
THIS IS A PILE OF HORSE [BLEEP].
AND TRUST ME IT'S AN
IMPROVEMENT.
WE AREN'T SAYING HIS NAME BUT
THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH, FROM NOW
ON IT'S JUST HORSE [BLEEP] FROM
US.
MY APOLOGIES TO THE HORSES AND
THEIR [BLEEP].
THANK YOU.
THE FACT IS FOR EVERY MINUTE HIS
FACE IS ON A SCREEN, YOU CREATE
MORE LIKE IT, IT'S A POWER OF
THE MEDIA.
ASK ANY WOMAN WHO HAD A
JENNIFER ANISTON HAIRCUT IN THE
90s.
OR ME.
ENOUGH WITH THE GUY'S FACE, HE'S
A MASS KILLER, NOT THE PLUS
SIZED COVER GIRL.
OF MASS SHOOTINGS ARE ALMOST
ALWAYS LINKED TO PREVIOUS ONES,
THEY KEEP STATS AND RECORD THE
DAMAGE LIKE GOALS AND A DEMENTED
FANTASY LEAGUE.
IT INFURIATES ME TO SEE THE NEW
SLAP THAT FACE RIGHT UP THERE
ALL THE TIME AS THEY REPEAT THE
SAME B.S. WE ARE READY HEARD
BEFORE.
MEANWHILE THE VICTIMS GET A
QUICK MENTION LIKE THEY HAD A
TINY PART IN THE HOLLYWOOD
BLOCKBUSTER.
DOESN'T IT DRIVE YOU CRAZY?
IT DOES TO ME.
IS IT NEWS OR IS IT SPECTACLE?
ARE WE CULPABLE WHEN WE KNOWS WE
ARE SUPPLYING THE REWARD WHICH
IS A TENSION?
PEOPLE DON'T COMMIT SUICIDE FOR
NOTORIETY BUT WHEN YOU TAKE
PEOPLE WITH YOU, THAT'S FOR
INTIMATE.
WE INDULGE IT UNDER THE GUISE OF
NEWS AS ANOTHER MONSTER GETS
15 MINUTES OF FAME.
I GET IT, I'M IN THE NEWS
BUSINESS -- HARD TO BELIEVE.
HOW DID I GET HERE?
I DON'T BELONG HERE.
BUT NOW IT'S OVERKILL.
WE KNOW THE GUY HAD MORE
RED FLAGS IN A PARADE ON
CHINESE NEW YEAR.
THREATENED TO KILL HIS FAMILY,
CUT HIM SOME SLACK ON THAT ONE.
I THINK WE'VE ALL DONE THAT AT
LEAST ON ONE THANKSGIVING.
YOU THREATEN TO KILL HIMSELF, HE
POSTED STUFF ABOUT
MASS SHOOTINGS LIKE IT WAS
EXCERPTS FROM AN UPCOMING BOOK,
HE PAINTED A MURAL ABOUT
KILLING, HE BROUGHT UP A MASS
SHOOTING THE NIGHT BEFORE.
HE TIPPED HIS HAND MORE TIMES
THAN ME AT HAPPY HOUR WITH A
BOTTLE OF TITO'S.
DID I MENTION THE FACE TATTOOS?
THAT DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE A
PSYCHO KILLER BUT I WOULDN'T ASK
HIM TO BABYSIT.
AND YET HE GOT GUNS AND HE TOOK
INNOCENT LIVES.
IF YOU CAN'T PREVENT THAT GUY
WITH ALL THOSE SIGNS, WHAT CAN
YOU DO?
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
DO YOU EVER NOTICE HOW CERTAIN
PEOPLE ONLY INTERVENE IN STUFF
WHEN THE RISK IS LOW?
BUT THERE COMES A TIME WHEN
SOMEONE HAS TO SPEAK UP, THEY
DON'T.
WE USED TO USED TO HEAR
NEIGHBORS SAY HE WAS SO QUIET,
THE LAST GUY YOU WOULD SUSPECT.
NOW THEY SAY WE ALL KNEW THAT
GUY WAS A PSYCHO.
BACK TO WATCHING TIKTOK VIDEOS.
IF COURAGE WAS COFFEE WE HAVE
REPLACED IT WITH INSTANT FOLGERS
CRYSTALS, THE VIRTUAL VERSION
BASED ON VIRTUE SIGNALING AND
VIRTUALLY USE THIS IN THE REAL
WORLD.
DON'T YOU DARE DEAD NAME A
TRANS-CELEBRITY, THAT WILL GET
YOU AN INSTANT BAND BUT RACIST
MURDER FANTASIES FROM THE
NEW YORK SUBWAY ATTACKER?
ZUCKERBERG AND COMPANY LOOK THE
OTHER WAY.
WE CONDEMN PEOPLE FOR OPINIONS
BUT OBVIOUS THREATS SLIDE ON BY
BECAUSE WE AREN'T SUPPOSED TO
SAY ANYTHING.
THAT'S BECAUSE DELIBERATE
ANTISOCIAL BEHAVIOR IS NOW JUST
ANOTHER LIFESTYLE CHOICE AND TO
CALL IT OUT, THAT MAKES YOU
ANTISOCIAL.
WE SIT BACK AND WE WATCH OR WE
JUST FILM IT.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS SCENE IN
DOWNTOWN NYC.
THREE WOMEN DESTROYED A
RESTAURANT BECAUSE THEY WERE
CHARGED EXTRA FOR SAUCE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT VIOLENT
REACTION SINCE BRIAN STELTER WAS
SHORTED A McNUGGETS IN HIS
HAPPY MEAL.
YOU CAN LOOK AT THOSE
BYSTANDERS, MANY OF THEM
SO-CALLED MEN SHARING IT ON
WHILE THE WORKERS COWERED IN THE
BACK.
I WOULD ASK THEM TO MAN UP BUT
THAT WOULD BE ASKING FOR TOXIC
MASCULINITY OR MISSED GENDER
RING.
THAT'S THE KIND OF ARGUMENT
INTELLECTUALS WANT TO HAVE WHILE
A STREET LOONY BASHES YOUR HEAD
AGAINST THE SIDEWALK.
YOU GOT TO ASK YOURSELF WHY
WOULD ANYBODY OPEN A BUSINESS TO
SEE IT SMASHED BY A BUNCH OF
LAUGHING JERKS?
WHY WOULD ANY EMPLOYEE RISK
THEIR LIFE WAS MIKE WE ARE NOW A
NATION OF SPECTATORS.
QUICK TO CONDEMN POINTLESS STUFF
BUT SHY AWAY FROM THE SEVERELY
WRONG.
THEY USED TO BE A NAME WHO
DESCRIBE PEOPLE WHO SAW THE RISK
OF STEPPING IN BUT WENT AHEAD
ANYWAY, THEY WERE CALLED BRAVE
OR CRAZY.
THIS PLACE USED TO BE THE HOME
OF THE BRAVE BUT IT'S TURNING
INTO A HEN HOUSE, HOME OF THE
CHICKEN.
WE NEED HELP FROM EACH OTHER.
I'M NOT SAYING THE MASS SHOOTING
COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED, BUT
IN AN ENGAGED COMMUNITY, WHO
KNOWS?
THERE IS NO LAW AGAINST MINDING
YOUR OWN BUSINESS, MOST OF US
LIKE IT THAT WAY.
I DON'T NEED MY NEIGHBORS
CALLING THE COPS ON ME EVERY
TIME THEY SEE ME DOING TAI CHI
ON THE BALCONY WEARING NOTHING
BUT CATS OLD HAIR EXTENSIONS BUT
THIS ISN'T ABOUT LAWS, IT'S
ABOUT COMMUNITY AND WE HAVE LOST
COMMUNITY.
LOOKING OUT FOR YOUR NEIGHBOR,
THAT REGULAR CONTACT WITH THEM.
KNOW WHEN THE POLICE, THE
BUSINESSES AROUND YOU, THE KIDS.
WE SHOULD BRING THAT BACK BUT
IT'S HARD WHEN POLITICIANS AND
TEACHERS AND CELEBS PIT US
AGAINST EACH OTHER LIKE A NATION
OF DRUNKEN REAL HOUSEWIVES WHILE
INSISTING YOUR NEIGHBOR IS AN
OPPRESSOR AND YOUR COUNTRIES
SHARED HISTORY IS A LIE.
PERHAPS THE ANSWER IS LESS
GAWKING AND MORE TALKING.
OR TIME OUTSIDE BEING A NEIGHBOR
AS OPPOSED TO ONLINE.
I'M NOT SAYING YOU GOT TO RAISE
A BOND TOGETHER LIKE A MOB OF
LIMITED GUZZLING AMISH BUT MAYBE
KEEP AN EYE OUT FOR EACH OTHER?
I HATE TO SAY THIS -- I CAN'T
BELIEVE I'M SAYING THIS BUT
MAYBE THIS LADY HAD A POINT -- I
KNOW.
HEAR ME OUT!
IT WAS LIKE 20 YEARS AGO, OKAY?
HER LAST GREAT POINT WHEN SHE
SAID IT TAKES A VILLAGE TO RAISE
A CHILD.
RIGHT NOW FAMILIES ARE HAVING A
HARD TIME.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I COMPLEMENT OF
HILLARY CLINTON -- TRULY, PIGS
HAVE FLOWN.
I THINK I SEE HER HUSBAND DOING
A BARREL ROLL.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST!
HE MAY LOOK LIKE A MILLION
BUCKS.
HE'S SO SMART YOU CAN CALL HIM A
NOAH IT'S ALL.
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK THE RISE
OF THE NEW PURITANS, FIGHTING AN
OPPRESSIVE WAR ON FUN, KNOW OUR
BATH.
SHE'S LIKE A FISH STICK.
WHITE, FLAKY AND SMELLS UP THE
WHOLE ROOM WHEN MICROWAVED.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND THEY TRACED ALL OF THE MAJOR
EARTHQUAKES TO HIM PLAYING
HOPSCOTCH.
WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION TYRUS!
HOW ARE YOU DOING THERE?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME BACK.
>> IT WASN'T MY CHOICE BUT OKAY.
>> I'LL TAKE IT.
>> Greg: I DID A MONOLOGUE
KIND OF ON THIS TOPIC BUT I
DON'T HAVE ANY SOLUTIONS, IS
THERE ANYTHING IN THERE THAT
SOUNDS LIKE ONE OTHER THAN JUST
GETTING TO KNOW THE PEOPLE
AROUND YOU OR SOMETHING?
>> I SEE THE RESTAURANT TRASHING
SITUATION AND THERE ARE SO MANY
OF THESE INCIDENTS NOW THAT ARE
GOING VIRAL WORK PEOPLE SEEM TO
LOSE THEIR MINDS ABOUT
SOMETHING, A LOT OF IT WAS ON
THE AIRPLANES FOR EXAMPLE.
WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH, MENTAL ILLNESS
AND IT'S TIME WE FINALLY LOOK AT
THE PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS --
THIS MIGHT SOUND CRAZY.
I THINK IT PUSHED -- I'M NOT
SAYING IT PUSH PEOPLE TO BE
SHOOTERS BUT I THINK IT PUSHED A
LOT OF PEOPLE TO VIEW THEIR
FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS DIFFERENTLY.
THE LOCKDOWNS, THE MASKING, THE
CONSTANT FEAR FROM THE MEDIA AND
CNN, WHILE WE HAD A HEALTH
PANDEMIC, WE HAD BEEN GOING
THROUGH A MENTAL HEALTH PANDEMIC
BUT NO ONE HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T NEED TO DO
THIS, THEY DIDN'T NEED TO PUT US
THROUGH THIS AS WE'VE SEEN.
THAT'S WHY THE NUMBER OF FIGHTS
ON AIRPLANES HAS GONE UP 3000%
OR WHATEVER IT WAS, NOW IT HAS
COME DOWN BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE RESTRICTION OF MASKS
ANYMORE.
YOU SEE THIS ACROSS SOCIETY
PLAYING OUT TO.
AS FOR THE MASS SHOOTER
SITUATION YOU'RE TRYING TO
PREVENT WHAT IS STILL
STATISTICALLY A VERY RARE EVENT.
WE TALK ABOUT THE RISE IN
MASS SHOOTINGS, YOU KNOW WHAT
THE RISES AND THEY SAY NO AND
IT'S MAY BE FROM 12 TO MECCA 15,
FROM 15 TO 20.
330 MILLION PEOPLE IN AMERICA.
IF YOU CAN'T STOP THIS GUY WITH
THE FACE TATTOOS WHO WAS A
WALKING BILLBOARD FOR CRAZY, WHO
ARE YOU GOING TO STOP?
>> Greg: IT'S INCREDIBLE AND I
KNOW HIS DAD HELPED THEM GET
THAT GUN AND IF THAT TURNS OUT
TO BE TRUE, HIS DAD SHOULD BE
ACCESSORY TO MURDER IF HE HELPED
THEM DO THAT.
CONGRATS ON THE NEW BOOK TWO I
ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO READ
THIS, A FINE WRITER AND I DON'T
MEAN THAT IN THE PHYSICAL SENSE,
DON'T GO TO HR.
>> I'LL TAKE THE COMPLEMENT.
>> DO YOU THINK THERE'S ANY -- I
AGREE WHEN YOU'RE SO CLOSE TO
ZERO ON A CERTAIN KIND OF
INCIDENT, AT SOME MOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET TO ZERO.
YOU'RE GOING TO GO BETWEEN 15
AND A 30 FOR TEN YEARS, I DON'T
KNOW.
>> THEY ARE SO DISRUPTIVE TO THE
SOCIAL FABRIC NATIONALLY THAT IT
DOES HAVE A DIFFERENT CHARACTER
TO IT.
WE HADN'T MANY CIVILIZATION
BREAKDOWN DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND WE HAVEN'T RECKONED WITH
THAT YET.
AT THE RISK OF GETTING THROWN
OFF THIS SET RIGHT NOW I STILL
DON'T BELIEVE IT TAKES A
COMMUNITY -- IT TAKES A FAMILY.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
CAN SAY IT TAKES A FAMILY TO
RAISE A CHILD WHEN YOU CAN'T
JUST CREATE THE FAMILY.
YOU CAN'T CREATE THE PARENTS
PICK UP THE PARENTS AREN'T
THERE --
A SOCIAL STRUCTURE THAT REWARDS
THAT.
THIS FATHER LIVED UNDER A
DELUSION, HE WAS OFF-LOADING HIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE STATE, TO
THE COMMUNITY, TO THESE
INSTITUTIONS THAT CAN'T DO WHAT
AN ENGAGED PARENT DOES WHICH IS
A SPOT FOR FLAGS AND INTERVENE.
AN INSTITUTION CAN'T DO THAT,
WE'VE BEEN GIVEN THE STATE TOO
MUCH CONTROL, CBS PROGRAMS, TOO
MUCH INFLUENCE OVER THE FAMILY
AND PARENTS AND FAMILIES NEED TO
BE INTACT AND WHOLE AND ENGAGED.
>> Greg: I THINK MAYBE THE
SOCIETY ITSELF HAS BECOME SO
BROKEN APART -- IT TAKES A
VILLAGE MEETING THE PEOPLE IN
THE VILLAGE WILL HAVE NOTICED IF
THEIR NEXT-DOOR NEIGHBOR'S KID
IS ACTING SQUARELY.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE THAT ANYMORE
AND NO ONE IS GOING TO TELL YOU
BECAUSE YOU COULD GET IN
TROUBLE.
>> YOU CAN INTERVENE WITH THESE
PARENTS WERE OTHERWISE
DISENGAGED FROM THEIR CHILD AND
PERHAPS COAX THEM INTO BEING A
PARENT.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
COAX -- IF YOU'RE A BAD PARENT,
THIS IS WHY I DON'T HAVE KIDS.
>> THE LITTLE FIRE WORKING
TONIGHT CEMENTED THAT.
BESIDES THE FACT THAT YOUR
MONOLOGUE IS ALWAYS SPOT ON, YOU
DID IT ON PURPOSE OR BY
ACCIDENT, YOU COMPLIMENTED
HILLARY CLINTON AND THAT IS A
START.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
WE ARE SO BUSY FIGHTING OVER THE
WRONG [BLEEP] THAT WE AREN'T
PAYING ATTENTION TO THE BAD
STUFF.
WE DO NEED -- THE SOLUTION IS,
UNFORTUNATELY WE NEED THE
KARENS, WE NEED THE WOKE, WE
NEED THE TROLLS, THEY HAVE TO
CHANGE THEIR DIRECTIVE INSTEAD
OF GOING AFTER RICH, SUCCESSFUL,
MOSTLY WHITE MEN ON TWITTER AND
START GOING AFTER THE WEIRD
TWEETS.
START LOOKING FOR THE WEIRD
BEHAVIORS.
THE PROBLEM IS WE HAVE BECOME
SUCH A FIRST WORLD PROBLEM THAT
WERE NOT DOING OTHER STUFF.
IT TAKES A FAMILY BUT IT DOES
HELP TO HAVE -- IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD -- HER KIDS WERE
OUT OF THE HOUSE, SHE WOULD SIT
ON THE PORCH ALL DAY AND JUDGE
US AND EVERY TIME MY MOTHER
WOULD BRING THE GROCERIES, BY
THE WAY, LITTLE T WAS NOT IN THE
HOUSE BY THE TIME THE LIGHTS
CAME ON I SAW HIM RUNNING DOWN
THE STREET AND I'M GOING DOWN --
I KNEW I WAS GOING TO GET THAT
NIGHT.
WE'VE GOT TO START CHANNELING
SOME OF THIS STUFF.
KAREN LIKES TO TELL ON PEOPLE,
LET'S REWARD FOR TELLING ON THE
BAD PEOPLE AS OPPOSED TO ME
BARBECUING ON A FRIDAY IN FRONT
OF MY HOUSE.
>> Greg: WE ARE BECOMING A PRO
KAREN SHOW.
I THINK EVERY TIME I GOT CAUGHT,
LEGITIMATELY IN TROUBLE WAS FROM
A NEIGHBOR.
A NEIGHBOR SAW ME PLAYING HOOKY,
BUY A PACK OF CIGARETTES AT THE
EMPORIUM, THESE TO HAVE A
CIGARETTE MACHINES IN THE
STAIRWELL, THOSE WERE THE DAYS.
YOU COULD GO IN --
>> JUST TELLING ON HIMSELF!
>> I DON'T REMEMBER THAT.
>> Greg: THE NEIGHBORS WERE
ALWAYS THE KARENS, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT, IF YOU
WANT TO TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
DEFEND A FACIAL TATTOOS OR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OFFER YOUR SOLUTION
FOR OUR PROBLEMS?
>> I'M NOT DEFENDING FACIAL
TATTOOS, ITS NECK TATTOOS THAT
I'M INTO, YOU NEVER LISTEN WHEN
I TALK.
>> Greg: TRUE.
>> I THINK ALL THE SOLUTIONS
EVERYONE HAS COME UP WITH ONE TO
HAVE APPLIED TO HERE WHICH IS
WHY I THINK THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
SAY WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING AND
THEY CRITICIZED THE THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS PEOPLE WITHOUT REALIZING
THAT A LOT OF THEM ARE DOING THE
EXACT SAME THING WHEN THEY JUST
SAY DO SOMETHING BUT THEY DON'T
SAY WHAT OR HOW THAT WOULD HELP.
IN ILLINOIS, THERE IS THE
RED FLAG LAW, THERE ARE ALL OF
THESE LAWS THAT THEY ARE
PRESENTING AS SOLUTIONS AND IT
DIDN'T CHANGE ANYTHING.
IT'S A DIFFICULT SITUATION BUT
AGAIN -- IT'S NO LONGER
SITUATION LIKE YOU SAID -- I
NEVER WOULD HAVE GUESSED, HE WAS
SUCH A QUIET -- PEOPLE ARE LIKE
I KNEW THAT GUY.
YOU SHOULD PROBABLY.
>> Greg: WHEN THE GUY IS
TRYING HIS BEST TO LOOK LIKE
HE'S NUTS AND WE ARE GOING
THAT'S JUST A CHOICE.
HE'S TRYING TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING!
>> HE'S PROBABLY ON SOUNDCLOUD,
THAT'S THE CASE.
THAT'S A LOT DIFFERENT FROM
SAYING I'M GOING TO KILL MY